[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
here a few notes about page turning the
first thing is to double-check that
there's a chair then I would discuss the
repeat if there are any make sure to
fold the pages paperclip them or tab
them so that the pages are easy to find
as a page turner follow the rhythm be
aware of the tempo and the general
movement of the line this will all help
you keep track of where the pianist is
in the score confirm that the pianist
will be taking care of page turning in
between the movements in terms of
actually turning the page I generally do
it around two-thirds of the way or half
way into the very last measure of the
page you really have to judge this based
on the pace of the music though keep an
eye out for double bar lines because the
last thing you want to do is stand up
for page turn at the end of a movement
in general I turn with my left arm I
also usually hug my stomach of it so
that my right arm is out of the pianist
way and I also take care of any dangling
pieces of fabric from me now going to
clothes wearing black or dark colors is
usually the way to go it's appropriate
to adjust your page turning pace to
accommodate what's going on in the music
for example if it's slow section that's
really quiet you don't want to be making
a really quick loud page turn equally so
if it's an extremely fast section the
pianist will need you to turn the page
as quick as possible as a pianist it's
good to avoid bringing in stiff or
disheveled scores that are hard to turn
or keep folding in now lastly if
something goes wrong it's not the
biggest deal because something can
always go wrong and as a page turner
you're sitting awkwardly next to the
pianist sort of far away from the music
and turning pages for music that you
probably don't really know just remember
that the pianist is also there and the
pianist should also be ready to turn the
page if necessary